hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to at dead of night
i don't know why that's doing that
i just loaded back in here i actually
completely forget what i'm doing but i'm
gonna remember right
now there was a dude a dude a dude there
was a dude in my last vision that's
right there was a dude
why are you flickering can you stop that
because it's hor
barbie hey you i see you there
jimmy i'm dr verse
i'm just here to have a little chat okay
oh no thank you jimmy i won't be lucky
right yeah you won't be long alive
with jimmy around you noted man knocking
in suit
man's suit and knocking on door in
knocking suit
the door is knocking hey what's up guys
hey how you doing hey can i take a
lookie lou
hey what's up hey how you doing hey i'm
i'm coming in
i'm in hello hello
is anybody here was there something in
here oh my god
an old heater marked dangerous okay it
looked like a bomb at first so i guess i
can be marginally less worried about it
but do not use tells me that it might
actually blow up if it gets used so i'm
assuming it's a bomb so i'm just as
worried as i was before
okay so is there a ghost in here
is anyone there is anyone there
hello oh what's your name
what's your name dr
bose okay interesting
you're now in contact with dr bose well
that's good
um i saw a man knocking on a door
telling jimmy he was there to help
yeah who was it was he you it was me
i got a call from
[Music]
interesting interesting very interesting
very interesting okay
what is this dangerous is there an old
heater marked dangerous
yeah why i don't know all right fine
then
what about amy holding a toy on fire
amy holding a toy on fire what happened
[Music]
oh yeah very funny yeah nothing like
third degree burns that crank up the
humor
i saw the little girl shouting to jimmy
to give her toy back
why did he take it
it's just the kind of thing he did he
was just
so funny like that what a hilarious
prankster
crying who was she the daughter of the
hotel guest
jimmy just some random hotel guest okay
i guess that makes sense
who does the sword belong to
i sword it was dangerous yeah only
moderately
only a little bit how about the
suitcases
in the chest who did they belong to
i don't know all right good thank you
very helpful
why was there a collection of whiskey
bottles in one of the rooms
[Music]
that's a good point that's a very good
point why is there a blood-stained cloth
in one of the drawers
it was mine i kept it in case i needed
it
it was your blood or your cloth or your
cloth that got
bloody why i found a bottle of
turpentine in a lighter
the things i already know about a lot of
these i don't know if i need to ask
about everything
i don't want to ask you to give me
anything where did the bottle of
diazepam come from
[Music]
in some people but not all who did the
chef's hat belong to
jimmy found it
okay good good for jimmy that's great
what was the coil of wire used for jimmy
he always kept it in his pocket but why
tell me what he used to be okay probably
this ghost communicator okay uh do i
make any connections about this
um well i mean obviously holding the toy
and then the
the turpentine is a is a pair what you
said about jimmy thinking that setting
amy's toy on fire was a joke
does that have something to do with what
you said about the turpentine and
lighter
oh come on use your big ghost brain of
course they're connected
okay so what here would this doctor be
able to tell me
about all of this what about this and
then the drawings
right when you said harvey was worried
about jimmy's mind yeah
does that have anything to do with what
you said about those violent pictures um
no no oh no my imagination is starting
to go
one way jimmy's on one
okay bye all right see ya i gotta go to
one
i gotta get down to one time to go to
okay jimmy
the [ __ ] has flown the coop i'm out of
here
am i oh god am i out of here
okay all right we're fine definitely no
not that way
okay good i'm checking mike
[Applause]
you [ __ ] you bastard
you suck where am i
where am i where am i where am i
hello jimmy where am i i don't know
where i am
how did he sneak up behind me like that
i went down the wrong hallway
hello hi
oh he took my device
he took my device i will take his heart
i'm at a dead end i can't take anything
how did he sneak up behind me i don't
know i
i mean i don't know how he works so oh
this is just guesswork
somewhere over here maybe oh there yeah
that's it
okay hello
i'm taking back what's mine [ __ ] you
can't stop me [ __ ] and there's a
flashlight also but
you know whatever thank you for that
nerd
i'm going now
okay hi
why that's what i thought [ __ ]
don't even try i thought that was his
bald-ass head
oh yeah because on the first floor is
where the next thing was supposed to be
right
where are you at
[Music]
oh my god no no go go go
oh my god who's there you yes no
god damn it oh [ __ ] me oh god no
no don't look go go go
so i don't hear him so i'm assuming that
means that i'm generally okay
i hear him way in the distance so i
don't think he's around here but the
crying is definitely near here
let me look at my scrying mirror i know
it's going to help me any more than the
vision i already saw
but you never know with these things
yeah
crying child very cry amy's crying
whatever
get over it it's fine you'll be fine
okay buy this i i did go by there so it
is nearby
this dude okay the store all right i
already knew about that
did i need to go back there no i didn't
okay that's all i get well that was very
unhelpful so i don't need to look at
that any more than just a reminder
where i'm going
this is okay to go i don't know
jimmy i don't hear footsteps so i'm
assuming that means it's probably clear
enough to go
but then again i got batted in the ass
before
so where
do i do what do i do what does this mean
what is happening
what do i do what
why what's happening
do i run but where do i go forward
am i going to die as soon as i go
forward
i'm going to go back in here so see
around buddy boo
don't i have the key for this don't i
have the key for this
key 104 104
[Music]
oh hey how are you
okay sure yeah that's yeah he didn't see
me
hey what's up how you doing no don't
worry about nothing
uh
okay
okay okay okay
okay so when everything goes all
scream and the icon goes red which means
that i can't save no more
i mean it means bad stuff is happening
so i'm gonna go
i don't think i managed to lock it but i
do have the key to this room so i i
could have but i don't
have i didn't manage to
we're going for it we're like right next
to it so it should be fine like
here in here
here let's lock this
okay door is locked so we're good okay
no
i've already been in here is uh
is anyone there
it's high energy but not enough is it
the room across the way
what about this one room 103
hey dork
is someone there
is it just out in the hallway by that
armor
which would be horrible
it's like right here
okay so it's it's like in
you can't [ __ ]
[ __ ] idiot stupid fool
i'm assuming i'm okay or i'm not about
to die okay so the air is pointing
straight
that way so it is there it's over there
it's it's the freaking armor
i swear
oh my god oh what the hell
[Music]
hello why didn't that happen before
is it amy oh there you are
hello okay so
i saw you scared outside a room
something frightened you know what's up
with that was it what was that
what was that all about i was trying to
find a doctor
[Music]
i saw a man knocking on a door telling
jimmy he was there to help
who was it
what you just said about a doctor why is
there an old heater marked dangerous
[Music]
well what good are you when you said you
needed a doctor but jimmy threatened you
to stay
does that have something to do with the
blood-stained cloth maybe
wait a while before making contact again
but where else do i have
goddammit okay so that didn't work out
as well as i had hoped it would
so there's got to be something
terrifying
hello amy
hate it
uh the sword oh i should have guessed
the sword i thought that was too obvious
i thought i thought it was too hard well
i guess yeah if you're making a threat
then you'd use a weapon okay all right i
get it how long do i gotta wait for to
go back to the thing
i don't need to know about this i get
the sword okay yeah i would have been my
next guess but i guess it should have
been my first guess but whatever you
know come on jimmy
jimmy you're not the only one that can
make those faces
is it amy hey hello ah damn it okay do i
gotta go out
what's what's deal what do i gotta do
how how do i how long
i gotta wait for how long i gotta wait
can i shout out for jimmy hey jimmy
[ __ ]
unlock it why would i do that why would
i do that
all right let's find out let's
let's see what happens you know let's
save let's save real quick
save current state and then hung and
call to jimmy hey
hey
i'm here oh no can't be gone no
what have i done i'm so stupid what have
i done
walking
idiot fool
you fool you've fallen for one of the
classic ruses
[Laughter]
well god damn it god damn it
what do i have to do run around like an
idiot
i guess i just gotta go go for a stroll
you know
[Music]
no you're not
oh my god it's fine
jesus go this way oh my god go this way
i'm going to a dead end
i'm definitely go oh no
well as i'm now an amanda a dab and
the end is dead and so am i
oh oh no oh
oh okay we're fine
we're fine he's an idiot apparently he's
stupid
and i'm smart now all i gotta do is go
back to the ghost room
probably and talk to amy again and then
ask her about a sword
[Music]
okay we're secured in amy you better be
there is anyone there
is anyone there what do you want from me
what do you want from me what do i have
to do die
if i save and exit and then come back in
with that would that do it
it's a bit of a cheat but whatever right
i'm back are you there you better be
there
hello there you are
okay you're scared and then there was a
sword
hello is it amy amy
hello good to see you okay scared
outside and then sward
when you said you needed a doctor but
jimmy threatened you to stay
does that have anything to do with what
he said about the sword
[Music]
oh no that's not good
oh boy okay booze
one booze okay so something about
booze and number one
okay so there's something else here i
gotta find it with the compass
i'm like a well-oiled machine now i know
exactly what is up
with this place
right oh
here
don't i have the i have the key to i
have that no
no i don't oh [ __ ]
oh god no
i'm fine maybe
i'm assuming i'm fine from that and
assuming every everything's good
okay everything's good hello
is anyone there
i'm getting a lot of buzz maybe i gotta
see something
you know maybe i gotta like walk around
and see something
you gotta be something in here right
hello anything to witness
i already have that in there
what's the two scrying mirrors in the
same thing there's the booze
okay well here i is
what are you doing drinking that stop it
stop it i see now that i've
messed up my own game because i've i
went through the whole hotel
finding things because otherwise it
would have i see now that it would have
been like a procedural thing however
you know i like a
fool went through the whole hotel in the
first
episode i don't need to be here
is it amy
[Music]
now i'm starting to piece all this
together the genius machine is working
[Music]
when you said the medicine tasted
horrible does that have anything to do
with what you said about the whiskey
bottles
only everything maybe
she told
[Music]
to feel me
staircase something about staircase did
jimmy push you down a staircase
why staircase i don't hear anything
i think this is clear
i say with confidence hello
i think i gotta get to the stairwell
[Music]
where are you where are you where where
where you over there
or am i supposed to go over there
there's a staircase somewhere around
here
no you no no oh wait no
oh god i see the sign don't kill me
where was it was it over here this no
not that oh yeah of course
it's right here
oh can i lock that can i lock that yeah
i can't lock that oh i'm going up
okay
what am i hearing
something's happening so it definitely
did something about this stairwell
so maybe i just got to check this on all
the levels
yeah actually you know what it is it's
it's about seeing things right that's
what it's all about i just got to see
things maybe i need to go up to the
third floor and see the stairwell from
there
that's what because there's definitely
something going on up there
there's definitely something going on so
if i just go up to the third floor i can
get away from jimmy number one and then
number two
might be able to get out of the zone
oh no wait hold on i'm just gonna go in
the levator
don't mind the levator you're not
hearing a thing man
weird how you didn't hear that four
three baby so i go to floor three
and then all's good all's good
oh yeah
[Music]
ah every time i was just there what are
you doing
what are you doing amy you there
is it amy amy
hello spirit's too distant i gotta go
all the way back around and get in the
thing
i gotta go all the way around all right
here we go again
this is efficiency there's efficiency at
work
it's pure efficiency it's fine
i don't mind it i love this hotel i love
walking around it's such a beauty it's
charming it's in my brain forever and my
life is gonna be influenced by this
moment that i
went through i can't get enough of it
[Music]
i'm sure that there was another place
that i could have found the key but you
know it didn't exactly work out that way
hey amy
hello hey okay saw you at the top of the
stairs
on the ballista
[Music]
oh
oh the bottom okay
all right that's great i'ma assume that
you didn't
test your lightness theory i'm gonna
assume that
i'm gonna assume that
oh god no
[Music]
is it amy
i saw you lying at the bottom of the
stairs what happened to you
but then it all went dark and i couldn't
wake up
i can't wake up anymore
well um
dash this is getting far
from my area of expertise which is just
a hotel guest but
i completed amy's story great
glad we reached the conclusion of that i
feel
closure okay good great well now that
that's over with
i wasn't paying attention to the vision
i got so um
i don't think i know exactly what i was
supposed to be doing let me just go to
the kitchen and look in my scrying
mirror to
see what kind of nonsense i could find
glad
i don't have to talk to amy anymore you
know if i got to that depressing
conclusion you know maybe i wouldn't be
inclined to talk to ghost either
i guess they're all dead so they all
died somehow
probably because of this goof okay so dr
dude
levator one
jimmy laughing jimmy laughs a lot
okay i just gotta go up on floor one
that it's helpful at least
okay but anyway actually i'm gonna save
that there we made a lot more progress
in this one than we did in the last one
now that i'm getting the hang of it i
think i'm gonna be quicker about making
progress but i still really like this
it's very very fun and it's very
interesting
and it's spooky it's spooky in a way
that you don't often get in horror games
and it's really well made i love the
combination of live action in 3d and
it's done really well
so thank you everybody so much for
watching look forward to more of this
very soon and as always i'll see you
in the next video bye-bye
you